a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono poi j
oggi siamo su amnesia che non gioca la
mezza non mi ricordo neanche io volevo
fare sta cosa perché vi amate
consigliato una custom story assurda
certamente è un praticamente mai
non lo so neanche a spiegare che dovete
vederlo ho visto com'è che scrive la
cosa assurda è questa è la tua storia
perché tu sei un pirata chiara pirates
erba di violente del suo isole wishes a
the prophecy of the sun records and go
on e stairway make you came in round
trust me no finga revolver per ios
theatre l'ex knicks plein air to find
chaise long island foro iphone di
sfalcio answers è fantastico non c'ho
voglia di produrre quindi iniziamo alla
ragazzi sarà una cosa assurda perché io
vi giuro ho visto due screen e mi sto
mettendo le mani nei capelli perché ho
detto ma questo non è un media des morts
prologue e va bene allora ragazzi
iniziamo
non so con che criterio mi consigliate
queste corde ma vedete che roba è
fantastico
rullo di tamburi è ok andiamo con i pony
vai così buoni rosa questo attesa questa
è la paura che viene da dentro
beh
andiamo a cercare il suo appeal
che cosa fatta mi piace questo ragazzi
questa media rendetevi conto sto
giocando da media
vabbè è la kasko un pub più epica che io
abbia mai visto
era da te tarchi room che non giocava
una roba così è così
raga c'è un vulcano attenzione si fa
seria la faccenda che poi tra l'altro
ragazzi io ho presente sto aspettando
avvisi a due avevano detto che usciva a
inizio estate quindi adesso
invece l'hanno rimandato a fine estate
quindi radio dobbiamo aspettare per gli
infarti dovete aspettare ancora un po
era uno di quei giochi pc che dovevo
iniziare ma non posso farlo perché
cucine fine estate ma nel frattempo
linee di di tenerci perché cazzo cero
fin qui
cosa vuoi mi sta osservando da
inquietante la cosa va bene sei fatto di
cartone sei fantastico e direi di andare
avanti ma veramente è una cosa epici
d'oro è una cosa fantastica tutti i
personaggi di di one piece allora epico
e siamo mi spiegazione siamo da ragazzi
qua non è normale questo è che siete qui
solo nella sabbia di fronte a me c'è un
fuoco a un fan e caldo va bene grazie
non l'avevo vista anche tu 6 ott
vabbè andiamo avanti a parte la
perversione esplicite non importa c'è
shopper lo vedo cosa stai facendo lì c'è
che cosa sta facendo che cosa c'è e cosa
sta facendo qui voglio dormire ma lui
non mi lascio a dormire lasciato mila e
ciò che voglio dormire ma lui non mi
lascia dormire perfetto la ragazzi state
fate messi molto male voi due
io direi di andare avanti ragazzi non è
normale che questa sia una mappa di
amnesia c'è un pony laggiù raga lo vedo
e c'è una caverna fantastica che io non
mi ad entrare lì dentro però va beh
perché c'è un pony che cosa vuoi c'è un
pony portali con te voglio vivere nella
caverna di dentro ma chi è il suo
ardimento che vorrebbe vivere lì dentro
va beh
sì ti prendono ha raccolto twilight
sparkle ok
vabbè se proprio vuole vivere la caverna
portiamo dentro anche se non so con che
criterio debba entrare qui dentro è così
bello fuori perché dobbiamo 3p dentro
sarà una cosa fatta e lo sapevo che
diventava buia dentro perché sono
entrato qui dentro maledizione apriamo
aprite raga a pista porta maledizione ok
bravissimo era la chiave era lui
ok dove siamo c'è laudano la oh mio dio
cosa ci fa gol ci sono ragazzi questa me
la dovete spiegare perché c'è goku
vegeta e frisa che ballano sta
succedendo qui ragazzi scusa è normale
sta cosa
e ci sarà anche nelle scimmie ragalo
nella chiusa cazzo sta facendo perché
c'è goku che balla perché perché c'è un
braccio dentro il pesto vabbè non
importa lasciamo perdere
me lo spieghi tu perché ci sono solo i
tuoi ospiti fai bene poi è pieno di
zucche ragala casa io cos'è sono apparsi
dei cavalieri
ben sei sexy sei veramente figo della
madonna
io devo prendere laudano alla lo
aspettate un attimo ragazzo nomi perché
c'è cosa del mcdonald's per che cos'è ma
perché ci sono le patatine nel
mcdonald's andiamo andiamo a offrirla
co.co.co way un happy meal
ma perché è e gustosa ma noi non glielo
offro perché so già che lui sono
divorati per traverso forse ve gela è un
po più tranquillo rendite la sua guai se
non dovrei lanciare nel cibo addosso dei
saiyan perché finisco male eh vabbè ce
n'è una scala più londrina c'è anche una
porta qualche problema ho bisogno di una
bella per aprirla sono troppo ciccio va
bene allora cerchiamo una mela per
aprire st pour la magagna mai piano di
sopra
qua c'è dell'aula non l'ho visto nella
porzione di sanità va bè quale laudano
questi numeri fa ci sarebbe una mela ma
dove la prova la mela cos'è questo
perché ci sono pezzi hardware ragazzi
allora ho incontrato guai
tutto il team di one piece ho incontrato
tutto il team di drive nova bay i più
famosi del team di dragon buffoni
l'happy meal e c'è anche un pezzo
hardware
insomma ormai base bene va bene la
ragazzi c'è io non ho parole è una cosa
assurda
va bene che adesso che abbiamo dato la
cosa di energia vegeta che cosa ecco
questa la mela e cresta lamela altro che
death note quest'anno vera me l'ha mai
cos'è il suo di testa dove riuscire a
portare stamera la porta magari si apre
vaia prete ok sono stato colpito la
delle patate anno erano delle mele anche
quelle raga mi hanno colpito mi hanno
colpito ma non sono affondato sono
ancora vivo posso entrare raga mi hanno
colpito delle mele non mi chiedete
perché ok sto andando male di
caricamento ma diventando osseo dio
cos'è quella roba laggiù
raga c'è un teschio ci sono delle porte
di aprire le porte non sono tutte chiuse
merda ragazze un teschio non posso
fronteggiarlo in nessun modo
allora andiamo a cazzotti e cos'è sta
roba cosa mi rappresenta il cos'è sta
roba qui buongiorno cazzo non mi attacca
restò fermo ok raga io topi so perché
sono teschio troppo bambino
cos'è e spari è sparito benissimo raga
sparito possiamo andare avanti grande ce
la possiamo fare è diventato macabra un
certo punto va bene c'era qualcosa qui
c'era chiave per sa che deve raggiungere
la chiave prima del teschio vai così
come così poi così la prendo la prendono
prendo prendo prendo mai verrai non si
torna indietro apparve pietro cazzo
tutto indietro lo posso fare
dovete usare la chiave vai vai vai abiti
apriti cielo fatta da che non so come ma
ce l'ho fatta allora poi ci sono altre
porte e 9
buongiorno salve senta io sono entrato
qui dentro perché non ho cos'è sta roba
c'è una chiave salve io devo uscire un
mio zio chiude da è chiusa
apriti a per gli abiti ok perfetto sia
per tali a buongiorno è stato bello
chiudi la ce la dovremmo aver fatto un
effetto la porta si è chiusa ragazzi sta
diventando sta impazzendo devo usare
devo usare la pozione perché sono muoio
direi di andare avanti anche se non so
precisamente dove stona perfetto è tutto
chiuso
la chiave funziona ancora m è una multi
chiave e posso usare la propria si sia
prestato perfetto allora entriamo ragano
so un insolito il prt sciacca si sta
cavalcando no c'è il cattivo risani che
che non mi ricordo come si chiama grazie
mille mi ha lanciato una cassa preso una
cazzi ciao
sarà bello rincontrarti senti c'è il
cattivo di sonic che è andato di qua
nomi come si chiama dottor
qualcuno di voi ha la minima idea di
quello che ho appena successo
senti cosa cosa cazzo ti facendo tutti
ma è normale che oggi ha visto fra raga
è un maniaco
devo riuscire a superare il maniaco in
qualche modo perfetto io passo vai vai
vai vai aprite aprite ce l'ho fatta
c'era un maniaco non chiedetemi perché
fa ce l'ho fatta superato mi chiama lui
cazzo siamo raga sta diventando assurdo
e andiamo andiamo li so perfetta un
rischio anche a superare gli scalini
pensate che questo mesto noi siamo qui
questo posto dove dove siamo finiti c'è
una zucca lega c'è un pony impossessato
per prima di prima di prendere i pony
levi svegliarlo colpendo la sua testa
con qualsiasi cosa ok allora sarà prendo
questo ok l'ho preso e dove riuscirò che
il prefetto ce l'ho fatta ma no ma dai
vai tranquillo non ti ho fatto così male
e forse devo dargli la scatola che non
so bene a caserta perfetto
[Applauso]
e a voi dovremmo sederci l'una di fianco
all'altra e discutere di che cazzo
abbiamo appena giocato con sera sta roba
aver accaduto fuori napoli è già prima
che uscisse il 2 perché tanto uscirà ho
deciso di far questo non mi chiedete
perché va beh io direi di concludere qui
anche perché è stata una cosa
assolutamente non sense davidov è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato
commento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook che come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete alcuni
siti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo un
prossimo vinto bene ragazzi
[Musica]